[Musik]
vor einer stunde hat sie aufgehört die
toten zu zählen
[Musik]
das ist obwohl es mitten aus der
handlung gerissen scheint der erste satz
in diesem roman stadt der rebellion von
einem englischen autor robert hamilton
und schon den beiden vornamen merkt man
an dass das jemand ist der auf der
grenze zwischen orient und okzident lebt
denn als in kairo die revolution im
rahmen des arabischen frühlings losging
sofort dorthin gereist und hat ein
presse kollektiv gegründet um über die
aufstände dort zu berichten
und in gewisser weise ist das auch der
kern der romanhandlung von statt der
rebellion in dem hamilton jetzt einige
jahre später seine erfahrungen dort
aufgeschrieben hat und wenn man nur ein
bisschen über diesen autor
herauszukriegen versucht dann merkt man
sehr schnell dass wahrscheinlich fast
alles was da drinsteht autobiografisch
geprägt ist und wenn man sich das
vergegenwärtigt dann ist das eine der
schlimmsten lektüren wie man sich
vorstellen kann weil hier in einer
intensität über die ereignisse dort
berichtet wird und vor allem über die
gegenmaßnahmen der staatlichen gewalt
der polizei des militärs über
folterungen über hinrichtungen über
massaker auf den straßen die man sich
denn doch bei allen fernsehbildern so
nicht hat vorstellen können
das interessante dabei ist aber auch
dass gerade mit der ästhetik der
fernsehbilder aber auch mit den
möglichkeiten der neuen medien in diesem
roman ganz extrem formal gearbeitet wird
wir haben schilderungen von denen man
glaubt sie sind wie drehbücher
geschrieben für eine verfilmung der
ereignisse dort immer wieder gibt es
kritik die in die handlung eingebaut
sind so dass man auch einen immer ganz
starken kontrast zwischen den
verschiedenen thematischen ebenen hat so
dass man das gefühl hat die wirklichkeit
in form von zitaten aus den damaligen
kommunikationsproblemen dringt in diesem
roman ein
und das ist von einer unglaublichen
intensität und dann gibt es einen
nachteil in dieser wirklich
erstaunlichen weg türe und der besteht
darin dass hamilton mit einem ganz klar
westlichen blick erzählt obwohl er ja
ägyptischer abkunft ist aber er hat eine
art des schreibens die dann doch weit
weg ist von dem was ich aus den
orientalischen literaturen kenne das ist
ein tristes fazit für dieses buch aber
die art wie es einem das erzählt macht
so viel klar über das was am arabischen
frühling schiefgegangen ist warum die
arabellion gescheitert ist
dass es literatur von allerhöchsten
geladen ist